welcome back how does it feel
excuse me
[Music]
[Music]
all right
thank you
oh max what does it mean to be home
i just don't want to present peace
somewhere else because of what i just
saw and that's that's the reality to
understand how that works but
i don't know really what to say right
welcome home
we're glad you're safe brother i'm glad
[Music]
and you're documenting
you're documenting it's important for
all of us to kind of see the reality
of what's happening over there
yeah look i i was told to get a gun i
was sold to watch youtube videos to
learn how to use an ak i decided that
this is my gun and i'm going to do my
best with this and and
if that's not something that's enough to
protect me personally while i was there
well then let's be it i made that choice
and made that decision you know for me
it's important that my friends over
there survive right this second i don't
care about answering politically
correctly or figuring out what to say i
have no idea what to say i have no idea
what i'm going to do right this second i
just i i'm trying to process
you know all of this and i just want to
go home i don't want to shout out to the
reporters over there the new the new
schools they're putting stuff like this
in areas of that sort of action
they're heroes because they're they're
the ones who put stuff out i understand
that process now
welcome home buddy welcome home so much
thank you so much welcome home man you
know you know you know you know that
beforehand
guys history just repeated itself this
is this thing started somewhere so
should we get one question that's my
question
we are all involved no i mean military
help coming in uh the reason why ukraine
is standing right now is number one
because of ukrainian people number two
because they for the eight years they
were in that conflict and they knew it
was a pressure cooker they just blew up
they expected it and the fact that the
entire world is helping huge shout out
to poland huge shout out shout out to
neighboring countries the way i treat it
was it was treated through this whole
process of living in poland i just gotta
bow down to polish people and then
beyond that the fact that ukraine is
getting flooded with help there's
literally military personnel
volunteering
so the fact that we're not
saying we're going to war of course it
doesn't mean that people aren't just
dressing up coming out of civilian
clothing and going over there i have a
video that was put together by
by outside nations that just like
you know sending their own troops on
their own accord this is not a military
operation people just civilians they're
just getting their guts they came from
war somewhere else and they're going to
ukraine and that's an incredible thing
and if we don't get involved this thing
is going to go everywhere else i think
that in 2022
following this action we have to
completely rethink the way we do things
as a planet and that there's never going
to be one person that can do something
like this ever again because we have to
be all checks and balances globally not
just country at a time you're right
thank you
you